hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the penultimate round of
the super bit chess classic it's shakira
mamiyara versus linear dominguez perez
and um the game is really really awesome
it features a move that you guys will
have a great time uh spotting so that
will be our positive video moment uh but
other than that it features a nice
queen's gambit accepted we haven't had
one of those in a while and it's uh well
it's just a very weird game all in all
uh so let's dive straight into it mom
and dad with the white pieces opens with
d4
we have d5 c4 and now d captures on c4
as advertised queen's gambit decline
accepted is on the board uh knight to f3
knight to f6 and now e3 going after the
c4 pawn so this is all very standard
stuff e6 bishop captures and now pawn to
a6 preparing b5 and c5 uh we have
castles and now uh he would striking
with the immediate c5 this is um uh
well up uh uh uh up until this point it
is uh absolutely everything uh the the
top engine recommendation b3 and now b5
chasing away the dash of the ship to e2
knight b to d7 bishop to b2
uh developing the the bishop i think
keto and the bishop to b7 uh dominguez
does the same knight beat the d2 and now
bishop to e7 we have a4 challenging the
overextended structure here we have b4
closing the queen side and now rook to
c1 going after the c5 pawn rook the c8
um uh putting the rook on a nice soon to
be open c file uh and the position has
been reached before knight to c4 is a
known move d captures and c4 is a known
move and some other moves that have
not been played all that much but here
knight the e5 by miami they are up is a
new move uh so already as of move 13 we
have a completely new game uh so let's
see how uh uh
linear goes about this here we have a
very nice capture first c captures on d4
rook captures on c8 queen captures
knight captures knight captures and now
uh bishop captures on the four grabbing
that pawn uh we have castles and now a
queen to a1 and here that is already
where things start to get very
interesting so you can see that the
material on the board is completely
equal uh both players have a bishop pair
both players have a rook and a knight in
the queen but white has pressure along
this
long diagonal he's going after the g7
pawn and here dominguez uh perez goes
for bishop to f6 which is very nice uh
but the queen the c2 is also very nice
so queen to c2 kind of says that queen
to a1 isn't all that impressive now your
knight here is hanging and if you
defended let's say queen to d1 now we
play queen to c7 and we've improved the
position of our queen from c8 to c7
uh and if white wants to repeat queen a1
now we have e5 so white will have to
figure out the different plan so uh
queen to c2 uh definitely a a good good
approach but in the game bishop to f6
was played which is also fine uh now
comes knight to c4 and the queen to c7
so you can see that the queen belongs on
the c7 square um taking control over
that e5 square rook to d1 and now bishop
to d5 uh we have bishop captures on f6
knight captures and now pawn to f3
taking control over d4 and g for squares
uh controlling the knight here uh knight
to d7 uh and now pawn to e4 we have a
trait here bishop captures bishop
captures and now pawn to a5 and if you
look at the position now uh the queen
side completely blocked uh
its uh bishop against the knight and
what what can you play here well queen
to d4 of course a very nice centralizing
move by the queen going after the
uh the knight here and now knight to e5
with bishop back to e2 and h6 now they
are creating some breeding room for the
king you want to get the rook into the
game g3 and now pawn to g5 we have queen
back to e3 and now rook the c8 grabbing
hold of the c file uh f4 challenging the
knight here captures captures and the
knight the g6 we have f5 mamjar wants to
open up the king side e captures we have
e captures and now knight to f4 and this
is the position that uh
i really really thought you guys would
enjoy mamadira played bishop to c4 and
it looks like black is without a move so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find pretty much the only move
that it doesn't lose for
for linear while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
black is basically in swank well almost
if he didn't have the one move that you
guys had to find that there would be no
good move here for black and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the move is of course king to h7 and
this does wonders for for black's
position uh not only does it guard the
h6 pawn which is a problem the knight
here will have to move white the next
move will be rook to f1 you're going to
have to move the knight we're going to
win this but now even uh after
uh king to h7 even if we go rook to d1
we can always play rook to g8 with check
and then shift our rook to g4 to help
out with the defense of the knight so
there are many many uh options here uh
just to give an example if you play
something like queen c5 you offer a
queen trade instead of going for this
beautiful king to h7 idea we just trade
for example captures captures we play f6
and now it's just a terrible terrible
position you want to go rook to d7 go
after the pawn if black prevents this
you can deliver check go after the queen
side pawns it will not be possible to
defend to defend all of it so king to h7
the only way to continue really a huge
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this you are a a expert an expert
defender of um uh well positions that
are almost impossible to defend uh and
now how do you continue here after king
to h7 well one thing is to play bishop
captures on f7 we give up the bishop for
the knight and f4 and that's definitely
an option so if this was played let's
say rook the g8 to check we're going to
play king f2 now rook to g5 it looks
playable but
it doesn't look like something you would
want to do if you have something else so
momentarily plays queen to f3 instead
uh and now comes uh uh now comes um
uh rook to g8 with check we have king to
h1 uh and now ponte h5 not allowing any
and any of the white pieces to go to the
g4 square but also the knight on f4
nicely guards the the h5 pawn so here we
have h3 uh and rook the g5 now going
after the f5 pawn and here rook to f1 by
mamedyarov and now of course if you
capture on f5 uh bishop d3 and of course
the white just wins the game so instead
we have knight the g2 and this is such a
funny looking move uh what do you what
do you even do about this now well if
you don't have any any move here
whatsoever you can just capture the
knight and even this would be fine
because it's uh it's it seems the very
unlikely that black will be able to win
this we have a bishop in the rook for a
queen the queen side completely uh
completely uh paralyzed that there is
nothing black can do to do anything
about this bishop as long as this bishop
covers the b3 pawn uh you can never make
any threats here the rook covers the f
pawn king covers the h pawn so not much
for for black to push for here so this
is one of the options the other one is
queen to e4 what uh shocked air played
but it's not not all that great of a
move now okay he's threatening f6 to
open up a discovery uh but now comes uh
rook the g3 going after the h3 pawn and
now you have to be very careful if you
play f6 we're gonna play king to h6 and
now uh what's your defense against the
rook captures on h3 rogue captures king
captures and g2 queen to h2 and
well not not a lot of fun so instead
after rook to g3 we have rook to f3
attacking the rook and also guarding the
h3 pawn rook captures on f3 queen
captures and now knight back to f4 so um
defended well uh and uh
now it's up to him to figure out how to
go about this position now one thing you
can do is always this bishop captures on
f7 because the queen guards the knight
so now is kind of maybe the time to do
this but the black will capture on b3
and you get this position completely
equal material queen and pawn end game
where uh white has a past f pawn black
has a pass b pawn so all in all yeah
it's it's just a draw but here uh this
is move 40 and uh well mamijarov still
needs to make one more move uh to reach
move 40 to reach additional time so the
the time control has to be reached and
he played queen to e4 but this now
allows dominguez perez to go for uh for
uh initiative uh okay now you are
threatening f6 this will open up a
discovery here but now just king to g7
and this is a lot of a lot of trouble
for mamiyarov you could also go for
knight captures on h3 you can even allow
this episode f6 checking to h6 and now
after queen to e3 check you can block
with knight to f4 and again you're up a
pawn uh you you you have a very nicely
placed king there's no way for white to
threaten you you will you will be
winning this so uh
okay that's one of the options but here
king the g7 was played instead which is
also very good queen to d4 with check f6
now finally we get this f6 move in queen
to g1 check and king to h6 and now uh
shakhtar has to find queen to g3
otherwise he's just going to lose the
game but he played queen to g8 and now
after this queen to e5 move it was in
this position on mu 43 that shahir
mahmoud resigned the game and uh as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the problem is uh you you can no longer
defend this if you try queen back to g3
which worked uh a move ago then just
queen e4 check and now after king h2
queen captures on f5
uh this will be
enough to push for a win we've created a
pass pawn and the black will not be able
to fend off all the attacks
and if you try
harassing the black king we will find
the sort of a safe haven here after king
to h4 there is no more uh there are no
more checks here and after let's say
queen to g1 we can play knight captures
on h3 queen to g2 now comes queen to e3
and uh white is simply uh other moves
you you either have to start playing
with the bishop then we start collecting
uh or you try something like king h2 but
not just knight f2 we go after the g4
square let's say bishop e6 the bishop
controls all the pawns uh but luckily we
don't need material to win this uh queen
to e5 with czech kings you want now
queen to e1 check king h29 g4 check
and that's it there are no more squares
for the for the white king we have to
give up the queen here and now of course
the position is completely winning
so it was a really really intense game
uh
both of them played uh extremely well uh
but i really thought that uh as as perez
dominguez perez really had to find this
king to h7 move in order to
um not just win the game but also to
survive because that's the only move
that doesn't lose the game i thought it
was a it was a nice one and that you
guys would enjoy it so how do you find
king to h7 well like i said you just
have to realize that that's the only
move that you can play and that's once
you see that and that
you will be able to
defend this pawn that you will be able
to
get the rook into the game via the g
file that you will be able to push f6
because the f7 pawn will no longer be
pinned so once you see all of this then
of course you find it but um
if you don't uh then you will you will
have
trouble finding it so i'm very very much
interested for those of you who actually
tried to pause the video if you were
able to find it and is it is it an
obvious move to see
uh
or or was it just a very very uh
uh difficult to spot for you
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it here are the standings as
this is the penultimate round so there
you have it uh
before the final round the leaders are
levon arun and wesley so with five
points
and the levon will be facing shakhtar
mahmud tomorrow
who is not having the greatest of
tournaments
whereas wesley i believe will be playing
uh
uh who will wesley be playing i think he
will be playing uh a rapport uh i will
check just give me a second now i don't
want to trick you
uh no wesley wesley will be playing
dominguez perez uh who won this game
that we've now shown uh then we have uh
on fifty percent uh no first maxima
sherlock rock he's in third then with
fifty percent uh linear dominguez perez
uh bogdan daniel dank and fabiano
carwana with three and a half yanipam
she end with three points mamadyarov and
uh rihard rapport so really a tough
tournament uh these are all incredible
players so it's always weird to see
someone in in the in last place of the
tournament uh like i mean here you have
mamadiaravenderaport i mean
former 2800 player and rapport who is uh
playing the the candidates tournament in
june uh
in last place but uh you know it's it's
a tough tournament someone has to be
lies but there's still one more round to
go uh i think a lot of
pretty much all of everyone can still
win obviously lebon and wesley can win
uh uh maxime can win and i think uh uh
linear already and fabiano can also win
if they uh go to five points and uh
levon and and wesley remain on five but
we'll see um you know tomorrow's the
final round so uh we will know more uh
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it and really huge congratulations if
you've spotted king to h7 i would like
to thank yoga spot keep donating because
it is the strongest move person uh tara
kaldalal uh rip market and uh lucious
lucha for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day